ahora les explicaré por qué del año 2000
al 2006 hubieron tan pocos
incumplimientos o faltas de pago para
hipotecas digamos que yo compré una casa
que costó un millón de dólares digamos
que el banco me presta ese millón de
dólares y yo estoy dispuesto a pagar un
porcentaje sobre ese préstamo aquí al
banco
ese es el banco aquí estoy yo y usted
ese dinero para comprar una casa y aquí
está la casa bueno pasó esto y un año
después pierdo yo mi trabajo y no puedo
pagar esta hipoteca más así que tengo
dos opciones puedo vender la casa y
pagar la deuda o le puedo decir al banco
que me voy a bancarrota es porque no
puedo pagar nada más lo que va a
arruinar mi historial crediticio y pues
perderé todo el pago que ya he hecho en
qué circunstancias puedo yo vender la
casa imaginemos que me prestaban este
millón de dólares yo no he puesto nada
de mi dinero si yo pudiera vender esta
casa por 1.1 millones de dólares pues lo
haría si la vendo por 1.1 millones de
dólares
o pagarle al banco el millón que le debo
y me queda una cantidad neta de 100 mil
dólares y todos están contentos en el
banco porque ya le pague lo que le debía
yo obtuve 100 mil dólares y la razón de
que todo esto haya salido bien aun
cuando haya existido un riesgo en el
crédito es porque el precio de los
inmuebles aumentó cuando se tiene un
aumento en el precio de los inmuebles de
las casas los departamentos etcétera
prácticamente los bancos no van a perder
dinero al prestar para comprar esos
inmuebles ya que si no se les puede
pagar se vende el inmueble y se obtiene
la cantidad o un poco más de lo que
costó el préstamo bancario y esto
soluciona el problema de tener que pagar
la hipoteca la única situación en la que
nos declaramos en bancarrota es cuando
el precio en el mercado de mi casa es
menor al del préstamo que me dieron para
comprarla qué es la situación que está
ocurriendo actualmente
digamos que solo puedo vender esta casa
por 900 mil dólares en este caso pues lo
que tengo que hacer es devolverle las
llaves al banco y lo que hace el banco
es vender esta propiedad por
novecientos mil dólares y pues bueno va
a tener una pérdida del préstamo y esta
es la única situación en donde se debe
de tener o se puede permitir declararse
en bancarrota cuando el precio de los
inmuebles va hacia abajo pero cuando el
precio de los inmuebles aumenta la
persona que recibió el préstamo puede
vender esta casa en un precio mayor al
del préstamo paga su deuda y
probablemente le quede un poquito más de
dinero para él así que hay muchos
incentivos para comprar propiedades
ahora pensemos en la dinámica que hemos
visto en los vídeos pasados dijimos que
del año 2000 al año 2006 sabemos que el
precio de los inmuebles aumentó y por
qué ocurrió esto bueno ya revisamos la
información no fue porque las personas
ganarán más dinero ni tampoco porque
hubiera bajado el desempleo ni tampoco
porque aumentará la población tampoco
fue porque hubiera poca oferta de casas
descartamos todo lo anterior y nos dimos
cuenta que esto fue porque el
financiamiento era muy fácil así que
fácil financiamiento los
estándares para obtener un préstamo eran
muy bajos y debido a que aumentó el
precio de las casas o de los inmuebles
que ocasionó esto bueno ya dijimos al
aumentar el precio de las casas baja la
cantidad de incumplimiento o falta de
pago de la hipoteca así que las tasas de
incumplimiento bajan se le puede dar el
préstamo a una persona que realmente no
tiene algún respaldo de que sea alguien
cumplido pero siempre que el precio de
las casas esté aumentando si esta
persona pierde su empleo aún pueden
vender esa casa y pagar la deuda pagar
el préstamo así que mientras tenga un
aumento en el precio de las casas
prácticamente no vamos a tener
incumplimiento de hipotecas por lo que
el riesgo que se percibe también baja al
hacer un préstamo así que el riesgo
percibido
el riesgo percibido de préstamo baja lo
que ocasiona que haya más personas que
están dispuestas a hacer préstamos más
personas dispuestas a prestar así que el
corolario de que haya más personas
dispuestas a prestar es que los
estándares de préstamo van a bajar lo
que ocasiona que el financiamiento sea
más fácil así que aquí escribimos que
los estándares de préstamo bajan así que
tenemos este ciclo que a lo mejor
ustedes pueden discutir si es un círculo
virtuoso o un círculo vicioso pero
tenemos este círculo o este ciclo que
ocurrió a partir del final de la década
de 1990 y que tuvo más impulso alrededor
del año 2000 2001 el financiamiento era
más fácil a pesar de que las personas
estaban ganando menos la población no
estaba aumentando tan rápidamente y
había en casas nuevas todo esto hizo que
el precio de las casas de los inmuebles
aumentaran y al ocurrir esto entonces
tenemos que bajar
el incumplimiento de hipotecas ya que
nadie va a quedar con deudas y pueden
vender sus casas a un precio mayor del
préstamo que les dieron para comprarlas
por lo tanto muchas personas dicen bueno
pues aquí no hay riesgos porque todas
las personas están cumpliendo con sus
hipotecas las personas sienten que no
tienen riesgo al prestar dinero para
comprar inmuebles
las organizaciones calificadoras
otorgaban muy buenas calificaciones a
otras empresas financieras les daban sus
estándares triple-a por ejemplo aún
cuando se tuvieran préstamos algo
riesgosos pero se percibía que ya no
existía la falta de pago de hipotecas
así que muchas personas viendo esto
estuvieron dispuestas a prestar dinero
en este caso las personas decían bueno
es que voy a recibir más intereses si yo
doy un préstamo para comprar un inmueble
que sé que me van a pagar algún interés
y que en caso de que la persona a la que
le estoy prestando tenga algún problema
pierde el trabajo yo no voy a perder lo
que le preste porque esa persona va a
vender la casa va a vender la máscara y
me va
a pagar completamente todo lo que le
preste pues me conviene más que meter
ese dinero al banco por ejemplo así que
más personas estuvieran dispuestos a
hacer préstamos y los corredores de
inmuebles y los bancos de inversiones
dijeron no pues excelente a nosotros nos
interesa tener más volumen de gente que
esté comprando casas y para satisfacer a
todas estas personas que quieren prestar
dinero pues para tener más personas que
pidan préstamos pues vamos a bajar los
estándares de los requerimientos para
hacer préstamos así que este ciclo se
sigue repitiendo y repitiendo y todo
este proceso comenzó por el proceso de
tomar las hipotecas de cierto grupo de
personas juntas ponerlas como un paquete
y después volver las títulos y así
venderlas a un grupo de inversionistas
esto fue entre comillas una innovación
que se dio a mediados de la década de
1990 no recuerdo exactamente cuándo pero
comenzó a tomar impulso
a inicios de la década del 2010 y esta
es en esencia la razón del por qué el
precio de las casas aumentaba y el
porqué de que ocurriera toda esta
tontería en el siguiente vídeo
hablaremos un poco de quienes fueron
estos inversionistas y una técnica usada
por los fondos de cobertura y aquí no
voy a decir que todos los fondos de
cobertura son malos hay algunos que son
buenos pero la técnica común de los
fondos de cobertura el al tomar ventaja
de este ciclo para hacer que los
fundadores de este fondo se volvieran
muy ricos nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo